tout terrain pour les livrer
aux combattants.
- Lendndnd départ est dans une
heure et les bénévoles discutent
de leur itinéraire.
(bruit du moteur)ususususususus,
c'est la mise au point
des véhicule
Car ce n'est pas pour le trajet
d'environ 18 heures qu'on
prépare ces camions, mais
la guerre en Ukraine.
Les véhicules à quatre roues
motrices, c'est dont ils ont
le plllllllllllllllllllllllllll,
le propriétaire du garage.anana,
une Toyota : toute la rangée
part ce soir et s'ajoute
aux quelques 60 qui ont déjà m s
de deux semaines déjà.
La moitié lui ont été donnés,
comme ce camio
épépépéposer cet ancien soldat.
"C'est le moins qu'on puisse
faire", dit-il.
Et quand ce ne sont pas
des cadeauuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu.
Martin Bridges a non seulement
fait le don de s
camionnette, il s'est offert
pour la conduire, cette nuit,re.
Ils vont traverser la Lettonie,
la Lituanie, la Pologne,
en Ukraine seulement, parce qu
les hommes qui sont de l'autre
côté peuvent pas traverser,
donc c'est la seule façon de
leur livrer ces véhicules-là
qui vont servir, dans quelques
jours, aux forces de défense
À des milices comme celle-ci,
qui ont reçu les camionsrnrnrnrt
déjà sur le terrain en Ukraine.
tout ce qu'on peut pour survivre
aux hostilités, y compris
surtout des gallons d'essence
et des pièces de
Comme citoyens de la Lettonie,
ils se mobilisent sans hésiter.
"Comme voisins nous aussi
de la Russie, dit-il, l'Ukraine
est un rappel de notre p
Il dit qu'il enverra des
camions en guise de solida
jusqu'au tout dernier
bombardement.lmlmlmlmlmlmlmlmlme
de la Lettonie au chaos'U'U'U'U,
ils seront au front.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canad